the truth is the truth is I have been
draining myself to a degree I can't even
explain it's been the last three months
of my life four months have been gross
two and it's going to get worse it's
gonna get worse can I talk about what
you're doing yeah yeah I can say I'm
here shooting a movie it's all over the
[__] papers it was crazy being down
in Australia shooting a movie with with
Zac Efron and because he's so famous
you forgot that like in America
famous whatever we live in LA we see
famous people it doesn't mean anything
uh it does dude here it's here it's it's
different different why what does he do
when he goes out we can't go out we have
to we have to get private tables
everywhere we have to like when we do go
out together we have to be like it's
discreet it's tough dude it's really
tough it's just so hard you have to like
dude there the paparazzi are like
everywhere they find sneaky little ways
to find out where the production is
shooting all and dude we're everywhere
we're not in one spot we're we'll travel
you know 20 kilometers Mike to go to
this [__] play they'll find a way
there
they're always around bothering sneaking
and it's just it's it's we it's creepy
dude it's creepy is he hotter in real
life or in the movies
he's pretty damn he's pretty hot he's
pretty hot he's pretty hot and Cena and
then Cena's with us so John is super
famous too you know and that's another
level of like crazy super Fame it's like
it's it's strange it's like who's more
famous Cena or Ephron when you guys go
out two totally different worlds yeah
like two comp like like that's what I
think is good about the movies like
pulling from two different fan bases
Cena's like uh
Cena's bro fit more bro bro famous and
Efron is way more chick famous Wow way
more chicks are gonna come up and
guys in the bar aren't going to be like
Jack
but dudes but dudes me and uh when Cena
was here he's gone but when he was here
we did my podcast and then we went out
and had
um he was afterwards I was like well
let's get you back to your to your wife
you know he want to go back to the hotel
he was like you know dude I just texted
her do you want to go get a Guinness he
likes he the boy likes his Guinness and
I was like I'd love to go get a Guinness
and I text this guy and I said what's
the best place to get a Guinness and he
said you should go get Guinness at this
spot and they have good kangaroo so me
and Cena lit up a bunch of guinnesses
and had kangaroo wow it's dude it's it's
rad it's like elk meat it's super it's
gamey it's lean but it's good yeah wow
you should dude have you never had it I
I only eat seafood I haven't oh you
don't eat meat at all right anything but
Seafood in a long time dude take your
ass to go get some kangaroo I'll eat
some kangaroo it's it honestly I thought
it was gonna be the woman at the bar was
like if you don't like it we'll you know
toss it toast it off the bill and I was
like yeah I'll try it I loved it
finished it I was like this is delicious
it's so good dude I think it's real if
you like gamey stuff if you can handle
it but he likes his Guinness and so he
had a bunch of those but he sat at the
bar
nobody really bothered him
uh a few people came over one [__]
came over you know like the absolute
[__] move we all know the move is
like Steve Steve I'm a huge fan thanks
man thanks man all right man [__]
love you and then that's it that's cool
but this guy's on FaceTime with his
homie drunk and he's like [__] John
Cena mate [__] John Cena and John
politely was like Hey man come on come
on dude that could have been a dick like
he could have grabbed his phone and been
like dude you know embarrassed him but
he was like come on dude be cool about
it man well yeah and he pulled him aside
and was like I'll do a photo but you
know don't do that it was like the
classiest version of
you know telling this guy don't be a
[__] idiot at the bar and call more
attention to me but he can go out Zach
can't really go out I mean he can I
guess but I don't know he chooses not to
it's uh he's got his dick sucked all day
that's what he's doing he's got his dick
he's got a rotating list yeah yeah
shifts everyone's taking shifts
um
tip in tap out now how long have you
been in Australia you said a month and a
half do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude